a great great man once said for he who
is not courageous enough to take risks
will accomplish nothing
shame on you my friend the odds of me
overcoming all obstacles never mind the
weight and mental health
it's like 0e it's not possible need
motivation watch a top 10 but believe
nation what's that believe nation it 7 I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being named after Mike Tyson and
coming from a long line of boxers in his
family to himself becoming a world
champion he's Tyson Fury and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take risks it's been a hell of a
ride no matter what happens in the wild
if I I've already warned because you
know what I've called from a walk I've
been thrown what I've achieved coming
back a great man a great great man once
said for he who is not courageous enough
to take risks will accomplish nothing
that was Ben no that was malbet early he
once said that so I believe I'm
courageous enough to take the risk this
is a dare to be great move beat him
Wilder cements my legacy as a great
heavy way of my era because even if I
would have continued after the Klitschko
fight and beat wilder and Joshua it was
a dominant heavyweight of his time that
wouldn't be good enough for me that
wasn't good enough for me I had to be
the controversial the outspoken
charismatic idiot of a champion who goes
and gets noticed by people or no
interested in sports political men read
about Tyson Fury I think I know that
person blah blah blah blah he said they
say that that but you know have you I
jump in the world in sports wasn't good
enough for me what the comeback they now
all are thing gone up in weight the
story behind is a movie this comeback
beat him Wilder after the time Island
after the weight and everything else
that goes with it it's a fairytale
ending even better than defending me
titles when I add them a man goes from
rags to riches loses all within a year
but wins it back again all of any air of
his comeback how great of a story is
that rule number two
just do you I don't live a strict
lifestyle I don't even live an athlete's
lifestyle it it's an absolute disgrace
to call me an athlete he couldn't call
me enough things absolutely I love to
show you is what yeah
[Music]
no shame on you my friend you know a fat
man's beat him and relieved him of all
these belts boxers
actually can tell does it not mean
something to to be walking around as
well no it's nothing doesn't mean as
much as this jumper means to make
nothing their belts haven't seen
daylight Center woman that's just the
person I am clearly they mean to me to
flood cause he's he's here trying to win
him back and he it beasts emotionally he
he wants to win him again and he's given
me all the stare outs and all up or it's
all doesn't really matter to me because
I've already beat him yeah so my jobs
been done either lead only impossible so
if he knocked me out ten seconds at
Murphy so what I've been paid a lot of
money
I've been heavyweight champion of the
world and I've been involved in somebody
fights and just because I lose one
doesn't mean I'm not gonna be involved
in big fights in the future and we'll be
rule number three find your motivation a
turning point for me was sorry it was
Halloween last year um I'd never
suffered any more anxiety attacks or
anything since about mid to late summer
but yeah Oh Ally of seventeen but I was
still drinking and still going out
partying on whatever and in value
nothing at all
but every time I got drunk I'd come over
I'd say right I'm dying training in the
morning regain mission I'm gonna be the
every weight champion of the world again
if you watch you were 400 pounds 400
pounds that was a man who called wolf a
thousand times follow me friends up
phone chain of gam all going come on
we're gonna do it Monday Monday come no
I do not wanna box anymore
finished turning point once I went out
Halloween dressed as a rare skeleton in
a fancy dress party
well now about nine of all can expected
to stay all nine gets smile
I had one drink I looked around me Anna
for what am i doing and I said to myself
you're telling me that you'd rather be
here with a load of kids half your age
because I feel like the old person now
when I'm thirty they're all eighteen and
like I know he's 21 over able over Ole
Miss sure eighteen they're all eighteen
nineteen twenty twenty-one and I'm I'm
like the old guy in the disco bopping
around I thought this is it you traded
having all I'm achievements for what and
I knew I couldn't do on my own I just
knew it I couldn't do it I said so many
times I was gonna do and believed I was
gonna do it in the night the next day
calm I didn't have no motivation to do
it that's another thing that mental
health will give you know zero
motivation to do anything zero
motivation to have a shave zero to brush
your teeth even have a shower nothing I
got back that night
I mean why fought I was drunk I come
home early shows all your O'Malley I
said yeah I said available for this life
I said tomorrow I said I start to turn
my life around and this was Halloween
night yeah 2017
she said yeah yeah I've heard it all
before cuz I'm the man who cried wolf
a thousand times I said I promise you I
said I'm gonna do it I'm definitely
gonna do it and nobody believed me well
I knew I had a smile on my face twinkle
in my eye
all I knew I had to get that weight off
by the way at this time I was working at
a 12 year ban I'd failed two drugs tests
for cocaine because all the time I was
out or still doing random drug tests so
I had cocaine in me system on two x
occasions the British box and border
control had suspended me license I was D
medically unfit to fight by the leading
psychiatrist in the country and I had
millions of pounds millions of dollars
in in lawyers fees to pay ongoing battle
in court cases
well I am so confident that I'm gonna
come back and everything's gonna be
swept away the odds of me overcoming all
obstacles never mind the way to the
mental health it's like zero eat it's
not possible he ain't coming back
because he can't from that day I've got
me tracksuit on in the morning and I was
gonna run T mile I like about 200 yards
and stopped and I thought right account
I can't run I've run all my life I've
always been a very good ruler and I got
200 yards and I was totally gone I could
fade me belly meeven I'm not it wasn't
like a fat like jelly it was like solid
brick it was it was a horrible feeling
of okay I'm gonna walk the rest and I
walked and while I was walking I was on
my phone and I saw a little video from
Deontay Wilder and he said ha Tyson
theory leh self down lays family down he
said he's that fat he'd never come back
he said and I'm glad he's gone cuz I've
knocked him out anyway just rumbling on
nonsense yeah I'm a fighter self you
know what I'm gonna give it you proper
you're my motivation now I'm coming back
to get you and and every day I'd go out
on the canal and I do a little warning
me sweatsuit and every day get a little
bit further until I was doing fall in a
5-mile again consistently over every sin
ever said nice never said no there's an
algorithm a you know even in the rain
that was out with me Mac on running I'm
gonna tell you something else I've
already won because we're from I agree
win the fight or not on December the 1st
I'm a winner
I think it's one of the greatest
contrast I feel I'm back from every
possible disadvantage to being healthy
I'm studying out 255 pounds in shape in
a mentally great place and I I feel so
great of coffee marks on me but I love
it I'm in the ring spiral I'm struggling
in the ring because it's so much not
hair but I'm so happy that I'm in now
my love to do rule number four rely on
your brainpower I must use every part of
my body mind and skill to beat Wilder
fights a [ __ ] or brawn or size or mass
or power or fight someone on brain power
a great man said that as well Tyson whew
yeah that's the one quotient so while
their us everything that I every weight
jump me is a world shut up so am I gonna
overcome that I'll have to use brain
power because I do believe whatever he
advances me on whether its speed are
fallacious ISM ability to jump I run
fast train harder Flynn Bear doesn't
matter because I know I surpass him in
brain bow because if I didn't I wouldn't
be here in this position after three
arrow or in two and half year of the
Ring a bow and all our stuff a bottled
if I never had the brain power rule
number five believe when they told me
your fight
Wilder I'm excited but I think for
everyone is it too much too soon
yeah you don't think those last two guys
you fight let's be honest right now if
they walk there I understand out yet
what you saying but I believe if you
good enough it's time and I believe I'm
so confident this is my time if I didn't
believe wholeheartedly I could win this
fight then I wouldn't be sat here today
and I wouldn't have overcome all I'm
obstacles to get me back to this moment
I've defeated so much already and come
back from so much then I've only got one
man to beat repair boxing glove gloves
on and it's a tough challenge duyan
table is a massive punch and he's
aggressive and he's bad we've been going
for him but he has never watched a
boxing brain like me ever rule number
six follow your dreams
wasn't confident character what you see
today was a very shy reserved skinny
little whippet kid and add no confidence
and I didn't know what I was gonna do I
knew I was gonna be everywhere champion
from the day I could ever think of
anything boxer and that was my ultimate
goal I knew that was never gonna be
moved by didn't know I was gonna get
there
well yeah growing up had no confidence I
wasn't given any confidence I was always
told I couldn't do stuff um and I'd
never do anything I'd never achieve
anything so that made me worse
basically I suppose when you get a bit
older you grow up and you smeet more
people you experience different things
and then I went down the path of
becoming a boxer rule number seven
respect your opponent's where we shake
hands with you on say Wilder after the
fight yeah of course the wall because
it's not a fight you know if he knocks
me out I'll shake his hand if I be him
I'll still shake his hand this is a
boxing fight this is the sport of
gentlemen a sport that goes back
hundreds of hundreds of years we're
entertainers at the end of the day we're
not archrival enemies I don't want to
hurt Deontay Wilder I just want to be
him in the fight and if he beats me then
I'll shake ease and then if I be in my
Opie shakin my aunt but there is no I
don't want to kill him or I don't want
to I don't want him to die or anything
it's just a boxing contest
we're just entertaining the public they
entertain in the boxing phones rule
there were eight make things happen I've
been around the world I've been many
many places I've seen many many
different things I've had many many
different life experiences I've seen
noise and the lows the Bulls and the
buds I've had the best food in the world
I've had the worst food in the world
I've had most expensive drinks of a
cheap drinks do you know the difference
is it all how you feel about it the
difference of a plate of food for a
grunt or a plate for a fiver it's all
about the individual on how the
individual interpret eights what they
are doing at that present moment it's
all about you as a person you know
talking to you what do you want from
your life and whatever you want go out
where and take it nobody's gonna give it
to you rule number nine
find your true purpose I was driving
home one day and I love a very massive
anxiety attack one of the worst feelings
I've ever felt in my life I felt that
was dying I was having a heart attack I
couldn't breathe properly I felt like
everybody was against me I felt like all
my friends had set me up even wife I
felt she was involved in it so physical
and mental and spiritual can you
describe a little bit more because I
think this is important we always
struggle and I know it's a struggle to
articulate yeah what others can't see I
felt I was having a heart attack like I
said before I didn't know what was
happening I felt pains in my chest I was
neon going blind
I was calling out to God to forgive me
for my sins
oh no one could be more certain of death
than me that day I ain't afraid of
nothing or nobody I don't care about
anybody I'll didn't care about dying I
didn't care about did nothing nothing
mattered to me I'm not bothered about
nothing I ain't afraid of nothing and
nobody monka me over gone today they
shoot me you got your bollocks do it
that's the type of person I am on this
day I was afraid of a child I was so
frightened of dying and I don't fear
death I embrace it but I was so afraid
it was like it was me worst nightmares
times a thousand everything that I was
afraid of him your life that I tried to
man up with hit me all of em I was I was
frightened I was a like a vulnerable
child I was fretted I didn't know what
did I do
anyway I got rushed to hospital I went
straight to the hospital the doctor said
calm down he gonna have a heart attack
accused everybody in the hospital of
being against me it was all explainable
what I was feeling I've never ever
experienced anything in my whole life
even know what anxiety before this was
the king daddy of all anxiety attacks
this was I was so sure I was gonna die
well nothing muttered I didn't care also
one it was was atonement for me since
got to the hospital I didn't die I'm in
this dying streak for about an hour and
a half hour and five minutes anyway to
give me some pills count me down I'd be
done drive-through my brothers and all
my family hours in the car to Lancaster
where I live I was adamant that I'd been
drugged or something can happen to me
and all the doctors
governing all this is I was totally done
uh soon after this I believed I was
going to end up in a padded room walking
around in circles
this is how buddy got for me I can't
tell you in words how I felt how down I
was when you lose control your own mind
you're in a bad place you know I didn't
even like today I look back on it and I
don't know what was going through what
were you going through I'm going through
hell I've been tortured by demons and
devils on a daily basis that's what I
believe I believe that God tested me God
give me the walls and I rebelled against
and it didn't mean nothing to me I
didn't want it when I had it
so if all right I'll give you a little
bit pain here taste this wall up and I
believe that's what mental health is I
believe it is a it could be a test
it could not be I know it affects so
many people in so many different ways
through on it's a silent killer it's
almost like carbon monoxide poisoning
can't smell it you can't taste it count
feeling what you done so many people
take the life's on a daily basis through
mental health problems and all those
look at him as a was a weak person or
she was a weak person well not weak you
just need help and sometimes you don't
know where to go new to speak to for the
help and even to today I pass I hear
people say no he's a moaner amis of
course he's got everything and he's
still upset he's never appreciative what
he says people are still prefer
attention yeah so what what do you say
to those because I'm not looking for
attention if I want to tell you to do me
job it's the most attention seeking job
in the world I don't care about tension
or fame I just want to spread the word
of mental health and get people who
suffer endued to get better you know
I've almost called on all official
official sporting mental health
ambassador oh I get so many messages on
social media and things and people
coming over to me finding me in the
middle of nowhere
Sanna need to talk to you for five
minutes or all professional sports
athletes footballers rugby players
hockey play everything asking me
questions how do you do this how do you
do that and I'm trying to answer them
the best work I don't think it this is
my purpose in life before it was to be
heavyweight champion in the world and do
I out to table
no no my calling card is to spread the
word on mental health and whatever it
takes to do I'm doing it and rule number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is work hard
now I've got a really special bonus
Tyson Fury clip on how to have a
winner's mindset that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
work harder on number two how will you
make it happen and number three what's a
weekly goal you can stick to and stay
consistent on
let's face it I need to be on form
better than I've ever been in recent
times I've got no easy easy fight ed and
I know that but winning is a mindset my
mindset is that of a winner and I'm not
so sure about Deonte wildest had beat
world champions before her be undefeated
man who was supposed to beat me who was
supposed to be Wilder never in his
career nobody he's never had to overcome
massive challenges where he's supposed
to lose every fight he's everybody's
been supposed to win so I don't believe
that he has that the mentality that he
can go into a fight as an underdog and I
haven't gone wrong for him and still
pull a fight out the bug but then
they're gonna I've been proven wrong in
the past by many so we never know we
never know what what what one has got
inside until they prove it now I know
I've been on the canvas and got up on
one fights I know I've been totally out
of energy behind them all guards I'm
down I'm caught I'm still managed to get
up and knock a man out I ain't saying
while to do that I ever the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be can
like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want to see Mike Tyson's top ten
rules a success check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there not necessarily the size
of the guys no means the basically the
spirit and a competitive in his heart as
we get older we lose our hair we lose
act if we lose mothers